quiero preguntarle precisamente sobre si
hay alguna alteración geopolítica de
papel de reino unido en el mundo con el
cambio de rey
hola pues estamos todos pendientes de
ello a la morir la reina carlos tercero
ya se ha convertido directamente en rey
de inglaterra y las otras quince de
naciones de las que sobran a la
monarquía inglesa pero es verdad que
todavía tiene que ser elegido como jefe
de la commonwealth aunque el 2018 ya se
dijo que él sería el sucesor de su madre
bueno y como puede ser el papel del
nuevo rey que llega en tiempos bastante
difíciles con el reino unido- a punto de
entrar en una recesión económica y
también en tiempos de guerra en ucrania
de la cual precisamente reino unido ha
sido un gran colaborador de kiev en este
momento cuál es el papel que tiene el
rey el rey carlos tercero o si por el
contrario no tiene ninguna influencia ni
en la crisis económica ni en la guerra
nuclear en ucrania
en efecto son días muy complicados para
el reino unido- en una misma semana en
cambiado de primer ministro y de monarca
después de 96 años de reinado pero
también la monarquía siempre tiene su
momento de mayor importancia durante las
crisis la reina isabel era recordada
con mucho cariño precisamente por su
papel durante la segunda guerra mundial
y luego durante la guerra fría e incluso
durante el 19 entonces no se espera que
el rey carlos diga
cosas políticas o que se discuta en
políticas concretas pero sí que esté ahí
para apoyar al pueblo en ese trance
bueno y si bien no se espera un impacto
muy relevante en la política británica
con la llegada del nuevo rey como usted
lo menciona reino unido está atravesando
una multiplicidad de cambios no sólo lo
estamos viendo con la reina quien
gobernó después durante 70 años sino
también como usted lo mencionó hay un
cambio de gobierno y es que hace tan
sólo tres días listos llegó como primera
ministra y formó un nuevo gabinete
dejando atrás la era de boris johnson
políticamente que impactos tendrán los
británicos con esta cantidad de cambios
pues está por verse pensará que son
tiempos muy convulsos es esperar muchos
cambios en relación a quizá el papel de
la monarquía es verdad que aunque la
monarquía inglesa no tiene mucho poder
para influir en las leyes sí que
mientras que isabel siempre fue una
monarca muy silenciosa y que nunca opina
el príncipe carlos cuando era príncipe
de gales sí qué opinión opinó mucho en
política entonces está por ver si quiere
tener un papel más activo en el futuro y
sobre todo pues en estos momentos tan
tan convulsos para el reino unido ya
veíamos que el presidente francés
emmanuel majo no se refirió a la reina
con un mensaje en inglés y que la reina
en los cinco viajes que hizo a francia
hablaba en francés esto es una manera
simbólica de acercar a dos territorios
que han tenido conflictos históricos en
este escenario y en este contexto cuál
puede ser el papel del nuevo rey frente
a su vecino francia y también por qué no
frente a españa
pues sí es verdad que la reina siempre
ha tenido un gran papel sobre todo en el
ámbito diplomático en crear esos lazos
con distintas naciones entonces pues se
espera que su sucesor continúe en ese
papel es verdad que tiene que andar una
línea muy fina porque ya hace unos años
cuando habló contra él por ejemplo el
parlamento alemán se le criticó mucho
por hacer comentarios al respecto al
presi entonces es una línea muy
complicada pero es verdad que el
príncipe ya ha realizado muchos viajes
por todo el mundo en representación de
su madre durante los últimos años así
que hay confianza en él